the person who sort of invents a new
sustainable
energy source or figures out how to
remove plastics from the ocean
it doesn't matter whether they have a
degree or a certificate what matters is
can they actually achieve it
that i think is what we need to keep our
eye on which is can they solve the
problem
today on chalk radio we're sitting down
with sanjay sarma the vice president for
open learning at mit
sanjay wears many hats he's a professor
of mechanical engineering a developer
writer a parent and perhaps most salient
for us at mit open courseware
sanjay is a learner
in today's episode sanji talks to us
about learning from the social systems
behind how we learn to the biology of
how we're wired to make sense of the
world around us
i'm your host sarah hansen
in august of 2020 sanji released his
book grasp the science transforming how
we learn
which he co-authored with luke yokinto
it's about how we learn it's an attempt
to describe how we learn with sort of a
biographical aspect to it
you know some ask me why is it called
grasp
right why grasp think about in english
when you really get something called
grasping something
i think the german word is similar
comprehension it has the word apprehend
you know you apprehend someone right
it's grabbing
in hindi which is one of the languages i
grew up with
you also use a similar word which is i
really got the concept you grab it right
so what does it really mean to learn
that's what this book is about and what
is the science behind it how does
curiosity drive it what does it mean to
memorize something what does it mean to
forget something
what does it mean when you actually
remember something but you can't access
it but when you get it once you access
it it also comes flowing out so that's
what this book is about and it tries to
map it from neurons all the way to
societal level
so what prompted him to write the book
for sanjay it was about uncovering the
history of schooling and rethinking the
methods we used to teach
i always wondered why we ended up doing
things the way we do and it turns out
that a lot of it is happenstance
and perhaps a historical accident the
impact of
what we were trying to educate people
about which initially was religious
books right and eventually it was
memorizing aspects of the book and there
was the greek thread that sort of wove
into that and then the industrial
revolution and so on
and so the question was if you went back
to the basics how would you teach and
what would you teach
i too am a product of western education
principles and i did well but i also
struggled
and so i started wondering what the
science tells us about how educational
systems should be designed
so once i started researching it i
thought oh my god the story needs to be
told so the book sort of started writing
itself and then i found luke and he
shaped it with me and that's what i like
to grasp
so what's the difference between simply
picking up concepts and actually
grasping them
according to sanjay what it often comes
down to
is having an actionable component to
learning
not just hearing and regurgitating
information
but locking it in place by physically
applying it
we
have this assumption that the learner's
mind is a sheet of
paper and the professor has a pen
and all the professor has to do is write
on the sheet of paper and declare
victory
and after 10 minutes 15 minutes 20
minutes
if the learner isn't paying attention
that's the learner's fault not a
teacher's fault
and that is just fundamentally wrong
and every parent knows this by the way
when we go to the classroom we just
ignore that truth
the fact is the learner is forming a
model of the world
it's like a plant growing
you can give the plant
a lifetime's worth of water on the first
day and say you're done
and all the potassium on day two
and all the nitrogen and day three you
can't do that
the plant pots water or sunlight or
a particular type of fertilizer when the
plant wants it by the way that's called
precision agriculture
it's a field right but yet we do that
human beings
i'm going to teach you all the math you
need in the first
four months
you should be done that's not how it
works
it's when you use the math that it
becomes valuable
and so
and every classroom
violates it every class violence that
curricula violate that principle
what marks something as something that
needs to be remembered or is valuable
well when you process it
right so if you have a nice conversation
with your child or your spouse you
remember that
right but the
conversation you had uh you know sort of
quotidian conversation about uh
you know something you know don't forget
to pay the bill or something yeah you'll
remember that but the conversation
itself isn't memorable
so engagement and purpose
flag learning
for the brain as being valuable and they
put it in a sequence that makes it
actionable
i've been working with sanjay for many
years at mit open learning and the
phrase that i hear him utter most is
how does your idea scale
i wanted to take this opportunity to ask
him about his focus on scaling
innovations and learning
there's something about learning that is
a human evolutionary
aspect of our existence which is
children learn parents teach and we keep
that so as an adult i learn
in similar ways to
how i learned as a baby from my parents
right as a child as a young person
parenting is not scalable
there's a reason we have
few children but we give them full
attention so i think our biggest
challenge is
there are lots of people lots of young
people lots of adults in the world that
need to learn
and the challenge is
can we scale what is
very hard to scale it's sort of the most
important question
and we can only do it if we understand
how people learn
and understand how technology could help
and how humans could help and how
coaching could help
but the scale of demand is so vast if we
want to make an impact we got to figure
out how do we scale this thing that is
so difficult to scale so to me that's
the existential question
one of the interesting things about
sanjay is that he's helping solve this
question of scalability through online
learning
as sanji will explain in a moment
online learning cuts out many of the
characteristics of traditional classroom
models such as one-way lectures and an
emphasis on memorization
so imagine you're in the desert and
you're thirsty
if i give you a glass of water which is
only half full
you're not gonna say oh my god it's half
empty you're gonna say it's half full
so for those who don't have access to
learning online education
is a glass half full
but it's still water
for those who can have residential
education online learning is quite
something else
it displaces lecture time and creates a
room for doing all the hands-on stuff
that makes education
doubly wonderful
the curiosity the coaching the field
trips and discussions the disputation
the fun the joy of learning the what i
call the magic of mit
and online learning gets rid of the
thing we waste a lot of time on which is
one-way lectures
so to me online learning has two very
different purposes it's a glass
half-full
for those who are
parched
for water it's still great water
so online learning it is
something that makes in-person education
much richer as well
by leaving time to do the hands-on stuff
that today is occupied by lectures so
that's the flipped classroom
something sanjay has helped develop at
mit is the micro masters program
which makes it possible for people from
all over the world to earn professional
and academic credentials for mit courses
they take online
credentials that can be applied toward
degrees at mit and other institutions of
higher learning
the micromasters gets rid of the
winnowing function
so let me explain so how does a master's
program work
you admit someone based on
letters or recommendations and scores
letters from people you probably have
never met schools from universities you
haven't visited or you don't know
admissions it's a venuing function it's
based on such sparse information
what we do with the micromasters is
there is no admissions
all comers are welcome it's online the
incremental cost of adding a student is
very low come on in take the courses
finish up
take the proctored exam it's not easy
it's difficult
when you finish you have a micromasters
and by the way
if you did really well
when you get into school we'll give you
credit for it so we reverse the funnel
so that's what the micro master says
sanji has been on this path of making
educational materials more accessible on
a large scale for over 20 years
so i asked him what advice he has for
other educators about how to engage with
grasp and how to get involved with
scaling education
what i suggest educators do is
first of all write down a wish list
of what
they would like to do what they would
like to see in the education system how
they do it differently and how it maps
to how they taught their own kids or how
they learned and how a good teacher
inspired them
you know i was involved a little bit in
the creation of open courseware 20 years
ago and when i was doing my dynamics
lectures
a colleague said hey can i make
recordings because i'm picking up your
course i want to see how you know the
approach you take to teach it
and so when i made the recordings i
called up open courseway and i said look
if it's useful to you i'd like to put
them up for what it's worth you know
because i teach dynamics differently
and one thing led to another and just
went up there and i actually think that
to
unself-consciously just share
yourself is something there's something
liberating about it frankly
and i recommend that others try just
make a youtube video of yourself doing
something you love put it up
and i'm sure it'll be of value to others
making ourselves vulnerable can lead to
something of great value for others
it's something we see every day here at
mit open courseware
so we'd like to say a huge thank you to
sanjay sarma and all of the mit faculty
who not only share their teaching
materials but also share how they teach
through interviews on our website and
through podcast episodes like this one
you can find sanjay sarma's teaching
materials on our mit open courseware
website
you can also pick up a copy of grasp at
your local library or bookshop
some other books he suggests educators
pair with grasp our make it stick and
peak the science of expertise
and be sure to check out sanjay's latest
book workforce education a new roadmap
from mit press
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from cambridge
massachusetts i'm your host sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
brett pachi and dave lashansky
scriptwriting assistants from nidhi
shastri show notes for this episode were
written by peter chipman
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you